cuál es otro nombre para el ángulo de
ape el ángulo de ape es de aquí ésta de
aquí está
y aquí está p entonces el ángulo de ate
es este de acá
bueno pues podemos ponerle también el
ángulo p a d o bien el ángulo b a b
vamos a ver si alguna de las opciones
está aquí el pp ha de estar acá entonces
la respuesta sería p a d
pero vamos a ver las otras opciones a
ver qué dicen estás acá dice ángulo pd
p d sería este ángulo de acá el apd
entonces no este no es el ángulo z
voy a pintarlo en color naranja el cp a
sería este ángulo de acá que tampoco es
y finalmente nos dicen el ángulo en a
pero el ángulo en a no es suficiente
información para determinar si es este
de acá o tal vez este de acá o el de
arriba y de arriba o el de abajo
entonces realmente para nombrar el
ángulo correctamente tenemos que
utilizar la opción c que es p a b